creo que es un tema de equidad y de
solidaridad
definitivamente tenemos que tener en
cuenta que en este momento si hay que
seguir trabajando en el refuerzo en esta
información es claro que la tercera
dosis es fundamental especialmente para
aquellas mayores de 50 años pero
definitivamente como lo comentaba el
doctor terrero de ms nadie está a salvo
hasta que todos estemos a salvo 10 es
supremamente importante que lo
entendamos como humanidad en realidad
necesitamos que haya más y más equidad y
solidaridad de los países que tienen los
recursos y que tiene en este momento una
gran cantidad de basuras disponibles
para su población que para distribuir de
forma más equitativa y lo segundo es
producir más vacunas seguir trabajando
la investigación de vacunas porque
definitivamente entre más vacunas
efectivas disponibles hay en el mundo
probablemente se pueden aplicar con más
oportunidad para la población en general